leute okay das war gerade der trailer
für community crashtest ziemlich and
krass geworden vielen vielen dank dafür
an die lieben pixel biester die haben
nicht nur ein trader gemacht und ihrem
auf die karten gebaut und machen sonst
ziemlich ziemlich coolen steht also die
sind ganz weit oben verlinkt wenn ihr
anbauen interessiert seid in minecraft
eincheckt die unbedingt aus auch vielen
dank natürlich an ist das sind die
server team dass sie das plug-in
überhaupt mit mir realisiert das haben
was euch bestimmt am meisten
interessiert dann kommt die erste folge
community clash die bild am ersten juli
also am mittwoch wird die online kommen
um 18 uhr also seid gespannt darauf dass
mit episch und folgt mir auf tour denkt
ist unter beschreibung wenn wir dann
aufnehmen das wird natürlich
dementsprechend vor dem ersten juli 18
uhr sein wenn ich es das schreiben und
dann könnt ihr mit am start sein wenn
wir seite an seite gegen die community
von dem casting kämpfen werden bin echt
gespannt sondern mein eigener spielmodus
und ja wir checken das ganze mal aus ich
hoffe ihr seid am start und dann sehen
wir uns am mittwoch spätestens wieder
wenn ich früher auf oder links wie
gesagt und checkt unbedingt weg sowieso
aus das war okay
macht's gut